hey everyone welcome to this hd tutorial
in this video i will be showing you how
to get the visualizer and use the
visualizer effect in the latest version
of itunes now keep in mind this is the
latest version itunes 8 so if you
haven't already watched my video on how
to upgrade go ahead and do that
so um the easiest thing to do is just
start playing song and i'll keep the
volume all the way down doesn't distract
you so i'm playing a song right now and
you want to see like the little
visualizer effect that you actually get
in windows media player 11.
um
and you can get this on a mac on in os x
or you could get a you could get this on
your pc which is windows or xp or
anything all you have to do is go to
view
and visualizer and make sure that is
checked
then the second thing you do is hit show
visualizer and just like that it's not
going to be the smoothest animation in
the world because i'm running several
things at once in the screen recorder
and i can't even show you the whole
screen but this is a really cool
visualizer effect
looks like a black hole or whatever just
a black orb dancing around the screen
with some lights
so
if i could show you the whole thing i
would but basically the visualizer works
and that is the one
there are two visualizers it's the
classic visualizer which will just show
an apple logo and it'll show you the
song specs down here and here's your you
know classic visualizers bursting out of
the apple and the other visualizer
that's built in if you go under view
again
is
itunes visualizer which is these two
little circles
so they might be a little choppy but you
get the point and i'll probably upload a
video soon on how to change the
visualizer how to uh download and insert
a new one into itunes just to use that
so that is how you get the itunes
visualizer as you're playing a song just
like windows media player so i hope you
like this tutorial and thanks for
watching
and if you have any other ideas for me
for a tutorial or for a tech just some
tech talk or an idea for me just go
ahead and subscribe and i will get back
to your video as soon as possible thanks
for watching peace